[Musique]
en fait ça fait des siècles que les
robots existent une forme ou sous une
autre dans notre imaginaire collectif
[Musique]
c'est bien sûr le mythe de l'esclave
parfait sans libre arbitre qui est
complètement corvéable à merci et qui
pourtant trouve le moyen de se rebeller
contre ses créateurs
mais d'autres imaginaires sont
disponibles comme par exemple au Japon
ou les robots sont plutôt bienveillants
très certainement parce que on trouvait
là-bas des mythes très anciens dans
lesquels les objets ou des entités
naturelles avaient des âmes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ces différents imaginaires
se mélangent on a l'impression que les
robots vont nous remplacer dans les
chaînes d'usines que certains vont aller
faire la guerre ou alors que d'autres
vont prendre soin des personnes
dépendantes sauf que des robots on en
voit pas beaucoup et encore moins des
robots qui nous ressemblent alors j'ai
voulu savoir où on en était réellement
dans les laboratoires de recherche
au-delà des prophéties et des fantasmes
de science-fiction
j'ai donc été accueilli à Toulouse au
laboratoire d'architectures et
d'analyses des systèmes pour rencontrer
l'équipe Gepetto qui travaillent sur les
mouvements des systèmes anthropomorphes
sur les robots humanoïdes quoi je suis
Nicolas Mansart je suis chercheur dans
l'équipe gebetto du lac CNRS et je suis
un être humain jusqu'à preuve du
contraire ça revient j'ai de faire jouer
à un jeu qui est extrêmement difficile
pour les robots
je vais perdre je veux pas que tu crois
rien il manque le roi noir je l'ai caché
dans la pièce et tu vas le chercher tu
vas le retrouver ça c'est quelque chose
qui est très difficile pour un robot ok
alors là déjà tu vois tu marches tu te
déplaces tu saisis un livre ça c'est
très difficile pour notre beau
mettre le genou par terre ça c'est
fantastique si je savais faire ça
j'aurai le prix Nobel tu t’appuies et tu
te mets sur un seul pied ça c'est
fantastique c'est vraiment un chaise de
toute beauté
et ici tu reconnais le pion noir même
s'il est dans l'obscurité c'est voilà ça
c'est très difficile pour un robot tu
peux vraiment te considérer un robot
d'extrême valeur
je l'ai eu mon pote
ah c'est bon du coup votre équipe de
recherche elle s'appelle Gepetto c'est
vraiment ça le projet c'est d'avoir le
marionnettiste le marionnettiste mais on
coupe les fils et puis la marionnette se
débrouille un peu toute seule vous
remettre le marionnettiste dans la tête
du robot avoir les algorithmes de
Gepetto qui font bouger Pinocchio
[Musique]
un peu
ça
en fait c'est des actions complètement
banales que je fais tous les jours qui
sont prodigieuses et qui sont qui sont
fausses valoriser un peu dans les
décisions de mouvement comprendre elles
sont elles sont magiques il y a
énormément de décisions de toutes
petites décisions mais cumulée ensemble
ça fait des milliers de décisions qui
sont prises en même temps avec des temps
réactions qui sont très inférieurs à la
seconde et le robot de tenir debout
faire un pas attraper une pièce d'échec
prendre aussi des décisions au niveau de
la perception décider de différencier un
objet d'un autre objet tout ça c'est des
décisions qui sont vraiment très
compliquées à prendre et ces décisions
là on les associe pas du tout ou le
public les associe pas du tout à
l'intelligence de dire je veux faire de
l'intelligence artificielle et je vais
faire comme mon robot se regarde de
monter un escalier c'est pas une tâche
intelligente tu achète intelligente
c'est je vous échecs ça c'est
intelligent mais d'un point de vue de du
nombre de décisions à prendre je vois
aux échecs c'est très réduit et monter
un escalier ça implique des tonnes de
décisions sans parler de tout le
contexte qui est autour se lever de son
lit trouver ses chaussons aller
péniblement en s'a sur les murs se faire
un café c'est une tâche une redoutable
intelligence redoutable intelligence
[Musique]
alors il y a une petite dérive en
arrière qu'il faut qu'on règle et ça
c'est une histoire de calibration en
fait ça c'est pireènes 1m75 pour 100 kg
sur la balance 32 articulations mises en
mouvement par des moteurs électriques
niveau perception du monde il a deux
caméras pour une vision stéréoscopique
un lidar et il est capable de sentir les
retours de force qui s'exercent sur ces
moteurs et sur ces semelles
les pyrènes existent aussi sous forme de
modèle c'est sur cette version
informatique que l'on calcule les
mouvements du robot
le but des roboticiens des
informaticiens et de liés avec succès
ces deux entités mécaniques et
informatiques pour créer un robot le
plus autonome et le moins dangereux
possible pour lui-même et pour les
autres ça passe notamment par un travail
d'étalonnage que vous voyez là pour
réduire les cas entre les mouvements
planifiés et les mouvements réalisés
en plus de tout ça un des points très
intéressants de ce robot c'est qu'il va
avoir des capteurs de couple dans tous
ces articulations à part au niveau de la
tête et des poignets et ça ça va
permettre de mesurer les forces
extérieures qui sont appliquées au
niveau du robot donc ça va être un
contrôle beaucoup plus souple qui est
beaucoup moins dangereux lorsqu'il est
opéré proche du main parce que si on va
lui rentrer dedans il ne va pas rester
rigide mais il va absorber le l'impact
il y a un autre champ d'étude qui est
vraiment le corps du robot vous
travaillez là-dessus aussi sur la partie
matérielle quel moteur quel matériau
quel poids par rapport à la puissance
concevoir le robot c'est vraiment une
des questions et pour les robots
quadrupède c'est une question qui est
bien bien aboutie on commence à vraiment
savoir comment concevoir un cours de
quadrupède pour les bipède c'est
vraiment une question qui est
d'actualité
[Musique]
et lui il va donc prendre en compte
cette direction prédire ce qui va se
passer sur une demi seconde dans le
futur au niveau de du positionnement de
ses pieds des forces qui va appliquer
sur le sol donc il a un modèle de
lui-même et il applique ce qui va faire
et il voit le résultat et il le fait oui
c'est ça tout à fait on lui a donné les
masses de chacun de ces éléments les
masses des jambes les masses de la base
du robot donc cette prédiction là dans
avec une demi-seconde dans le futur il
le fait 500 fois par seconde et après au
niveau du vraiment du calcul bas niveau
des moteurs il le fait 10 000 fois par
seconde OK
j'ai l'impression d'être dans le futur
là que bon
[Musique]
faire un robot humanoïde c'est un petit
peu comme essayer de calculer les
décimales de Pi primo vous n'y arriverez
pas et secondo c'est pas vraiment le but
le but c'est d'avoir un cas pratique une
espèce de défi autour duquel les
chercheurs peuvent se retrouver pour
parler entre des disciplines qui s'en ça
n'auraient pas de raison d'échanger
c'est vraiment par nature la robotique
une science qui est connexe et la
robotique a aussi cette propriété d'être
de connecter la science dure des maths
des maths qui sont vraiment sur papier
et de la technologie on est vraiment
aussi à l'interface entre les deux et
toutes les connaissances que vous
produisez elle circule au sein d'une
communauté mondiale librement il y a pas
de brevet ici il y a pas de tout et
public open source et partager le CNRS a
vraiment pour objectif de produire de la
connaissance et de la mettre à
disposition au sens large on publie sous
licence ouverte on se forme nos
logiciels solutions maintenant nos
concepts mécaniques ou licences c'est
vraiment un souhait dans l'équipe qu'on
a de mettre à disposition de la
communauté au sens large alors quelle
sera la place des robots humanoïdes dans
le futur va savoir mais je me dis que ce
serait quand même fou qu'il réussisse à
changer nos vies sans jamais réellement
exister sans qu'on croise le robot
humanoïdes dans la rue jamais donc le
moment où ils vont se rebeller contre
nous pour demander des droits
l'Apocalypse des robots tueurs c'est pas
pour tout de suite alors la blague dans
le domaine c'est dire pour éviter
l'Apocalypse des robots tueurs pensez à
fermer les portes parce qu'on est au
point où pour l'instant le robot ils
arrivent pas à marcher jusqu'à la porte
et à l'ouvrir déjà une porte ça c'est
déjà dur alors une variété de porte une
porte qui glisse une porte qui s'ouvre
on se pousse en se tirant avec une
poignée ronde ça c'est de faire un peu
de jeu
avec la clé de mettre la clé dans la
serrure donc non on est vraiment loin
d'avoir un robot qui qui fonctionne pour
ça c'est quelque chose qui est trop
difficile mais peut-être qu'ils auront
changé notre manière d'opérer des
cancers de faire voler automatiquement
des avions ou de faire marcher des
revers sur Mars autrement dit les
recherches menées sur les robots
humanoïdes auront des impacts sur les
mathématiques l'informatique ou même de
la médecine écoute je crois que je t'ai
mal jugé sans rancune
[Musique]